go we've got some big fans of the game
uh with us now and we'd like to welcome
them to the show i'll start with you
david i know that you are a fan of the
game but you also work in the medical
school and tell us about your work at
ponce medical so ponce medical school is
a medical school in puerto rico it's
part of the u.s health system and we
just announced that we're building a new
medical school in st louis it's exciting
and we concentrate on getting more
people from underrepresented minorities
into the health care workforce to become
doctors
and your expansion to st louis why why
we're building it in st louis to in
north st louis up on the peru at igo
site in the north side uh for two
reasons one when you build medical
schools in communities of need it really
improves the health outcomes to those
communities and second st louis is a
great place to expand what we call
cultural competency in medicine how well
that patient interacts with the
physician and concentrates on that and
st louis sitting right in the middle of
america with the large demographic
changes happening in the midwest can
position us as one of the leaders in
health delivery very strategic indeed
and speaking of strategy i know connor
you're a chess fan and you were telling
me that you're a big fan of the
streamers you must follow hikaru
regularly yeah absolutely i mean i love
watching hikaru watching wesley so in
karuna right now in the studio was
actually a fantastic experience so it's
very exciting to be here you
you're saying he's hikari you're only a
fan you're a fan of who else what are
the other big names oh i watch uh levy
rosman gotham chess and i watch eric
rosen quite a bit eric navarro and the
uh botez sisters so you watch all the
big names yeah
do you watch a guy named maurice ashley
at all sometimes you know
i definitely watched a sewer i'll tell
ya
don't worry
what about the battle between the two of
you father and son go at it what happens
at about age 10 he started to beat me
you know it's the way it goes in life
right
it sure does tell us where you are uh
right now at university connor and sure
and how much chess goes on there yeah so
i'm actually overseas in uh dublin
ireland right now and uh go to a school
called rcsi but there is a ton of chess
there actually i mean if you watch and
go through the dublin streets there's
more
chess games on like grafton street than
i'd actually would be expecting so it's
very fun just to walk you can just sit
down at any of the
seats and just start playing kind of
like it is here yeah and what happens
when you play uh the dubliners oh
sometimes i lose quite bad
but other times it goes all right you
know they're a very mixed range of uh
ratings there yeah fantastic well thank
you so much for being fans of the game
thanks for the work that you're doing
dr david lenahan as you bring more
medical uh intelligence and and access
to the to the community we really
appreciate it david and conor lanahin we
got fans from all over
but they're not too smart about the
streamers
[Laughter]
i think connor's got it down
they all become friends you know how it
goes maurice
more haters become friends thank you
both for joining us thank you thank you
for coming online david and connor and
alejandra we're gonna have more special
guests